I have opposed his nomination from the
beginning I'm a person from the
beginning
I think the nomination should be
withdrawn I strongly believe judge
Kavanaugh should withdraw from
consideration and the president should
withdraw this nomination if Kavanaugh
won't do it voluntarily I join the
leader Schumer and Kali for judge
Kavanagh to withdraw his name from
consideration shocker
we told you this is gonna happen the
longer the Republicans allow Brett
Kavanaugh to twist in the wind the more
concessions they granted to his
last-minute accusers the uglier it was
going to get you know when musicals the
11 o'clock number always arrives right
on time to close out the show well the
11 o'clock number and the Cavanaugh
confirmation saga has arrived oh he
looks adorable on that stage so of
course porn star lawyer Michael avenatti
delivers a gift today he dropped an
affidavit in which this woman Julie
sweat Nick claims that Kavanagh while a
high school student in the early 80s
spiked drinks at house parties to loosen
girls inhibitions and then essentially
groom them to be gang-raped inside rooms
so at Nick further alleges that Kavanagh
was present at one such party in
approximately 1982 when she herself was
gang-raped though she says he didn't
take part in it sweat Nick claims that
there are witnesses who can vouch for
her account we haven't heard from them
yet reacting to these outrageous charges
Cavanaugh today said the following this
is ridiculous and from the twilight zone
I don't know who this is and this never
happened now this is the third in a
series of what certainly appears to be a
carefully timed and coordinated smear
campaign on Kavanagh
first there was Christian blase Ford
who's still scheduled I said to testify
tomorrow morning before the Senate
Judiciary Committee exactly no one has
corroborated her claims and the
polygraph tests that she submitted to
the Judiciary Committee today
every Sukkot was conducted by Cory
Booker we have more on that in a few
moments then from stage further left
came social justice advocate Deborah
Ramirez who claimed that Cavanaugh
exposed himself to her during the
freshman year at Yale
Ramirez however may have exposed the
holes and her own salacious story by
admitting to friends that she couldn't
be quite sure if Cavanaugh was in fact
the guilty party again there are no
corroborating witnesses Cavanaugh has
strenuously denied that it happened and
Ramirez herself admits to being bombed
slurring her words at the time and she
conceded that her memory was quote foggy
and then today we saw a new addition to
the playbill ms sweat neck now like the
other two heroines of the anti Cavanaugh
resistance her allegations are already
getting bad reviews
she says she attended at least ten
parties where gang rapes were taking
place what she also says that she went
back to one such party in approximately
1982 after knowing that these gang rapes
were taking place were then she herself
was raped and it's important to note in
1982 she was a sophomore in college how
many college students do you know who
attend high school functions where gang
rapes had previously occurred none of it
makes much sense at all but this does
tonight we're learning a lot more about
a vanadis new prize miss sweat Nick
according to Politico her ex-boyfriend
paints a disturbing picture of her own
character in a phone interview with
Politico he said this about a 2001
injunction right after I broke up with
her sweat neck she was threatening my
family threatening my wife and
threatening to do harm to my baby at
that time know a lot about her she's not
credible at all he said not at all Wow
despite all that of course the media
today did what they always do try to
make President Trump out to be the bad
guy in all this another choreographed
performance
if you don't mind after I'm finished if
we juror Hallie or Vivienne or one of
our female colleagues could go after me
that would be great
what what is what is that gonna be I
think we great a foot if a female what
does it mean we're know what does it
mean be great if a female reporter were
to ask you a question about the this
issue so if you don't mind I wouldn't
mind that at all I wouldn't mind it at a
heart well let me wouldn't make any
difference to me today to follow up on a
question that a colleague asked as well
let me follow up on Jim's question mr.
president let me follow up on Jim's
question that I don't think we got an
answer to no collusion there the
president though he wasn't rattled by
the swarm and he gave his own kind of
instant review of these last minute
theatrics it's a very tough situation
for a woman there's no question about it
I'd like to hear a story yes well we're
giving their time they're gonna have a
big shot at speaking and making their
case and you know what I could be
persuaded also I think when you really
look at it all it's not going to change
any of the Democrats Minds they're
obstructionists they're actually con
artists because they know how quality
this man is and they've destroyed a
man's reputation and they want to
destroy it even more and they know it's
a big fat con job and they go into a
room and I guarantee you they laugh like
hell and what they pulled off on you and
on the public they laughed like hell I
thoroughly enjoyed this press conference
at the UN today the entire allegation
Act I think is getting old the
last-minute solos are not credible and
the reporters chorus falling flat
my prediction after all the hype after
all the bright lights all of its faded
after we've heard from the left about
this Cavanaugh takedown effort all of it
this production will close out of town a
total flop and despite all the hysteria
Cavanaugh will finally get the featured
role he deserves and he's prepared for
his entire life
a seat on the Supreme Court of the
United States and I have two words life
tenure and that's the angle